[Music]
you guys know
that scott fitzgerald
what the hell oh he didn't yeah he wrote
it
yeah i'm just sleeping what about scott
fitzgerald
the great gatsby story you know you know
the great gatsby he wrote the girl
yesterday
leonardo dicaprio no wait what he was in
the movie he didn't write the uh
anthem the national anthem oh that's a
scott key
i don't know i'm confused then you know
your history that's pretty good not
really
not like joe i think this was an f name
french scott key yeah i just know random
[ __ ]
joe knows history so the great gatsby
was
published in 1925 i think yes
he was the author uh yes f scott
fitzgerald
was the author what about travis scott
um he was not what's he doing right
there right down there he was not even
a thought okay okay
anyway the reason why we're talking
about the great gatsby is because now
officially that we're the fact that
we're in 2021
uh the great gatsby is now in the public
domain
whoa you can steal the story you can
just make it you can just make it now
you don't need a license because now
it's like free range that's stupid what
is it 100 years or something
so what's the f scott fitzgerald
mcdonald's meal
[Laughter]
yeah so a loaf of bread
a half a loaf of bread and some water
rations
some ice water because they wrote it
during the great depression or something
right
yeah is that the great depression 1925
it's great something yeah uh no your
time will be live
late i think it's 1930s so what is the
time like frame is it 100 years or
something no
so here's the thing so every year on
january 1st
there's a new bundle that enters the
public domain
because previously the copyright in the
united states
laws it would expire after 75 years
75 but as of 1998 works
published between 1923 and 1977
they expire after 95 years thanks for
our hack
congress and money so and disney mainly
disney wants to protect a lot of us
because mickey mouse
they were like invented what in the 30s
uh yeah so like
i know mary poppins is gonna come out
pretty soon
because we could do whatever so [ __ ]
disney and we could do it or not
because it only lasts longer
so mickey mickey was supposed to be
available like years ago and then they
extended all this [ __ ]
oh so you can't that's also [ __ ] up
why do they let that happen
because they're paid for by by these big
companies no i'm saying why do they
allow mickey to be free to everyone well
because it becomes public domain it's
like part of
it's like history when you hear about
greek gods and [ __ ] that's all
public domain now obviously because that
was like their stories of their culture
and [ __ ]
or like generic drugs like how
they like brands owe them yeah the
patent they can own the patent for a
certain amount of time and then what
that
once that time is up then other brands
can make that same drug and
have it be a generic drug yeah that
makes sense it's for the people
it's good for everyone that you like
things that are part of your culture and
things that are
like helpful are available i don't know
if it's good for everyone to start doing
mickey things yeah
we could do our version of mickey yeah
but not a lot to molest
mickey like that think about like doing
a superman movie
that you get to do jerry siegel and joe
schuster who created it
long since dead not gonna exactly be
suffering
by any of that uh like you making money
off of it or anything like that
what if you have an interesting take on
superman that nobody knows that's pretty
cool wouldn't that fall into the parody
law
well you i no no i'm talking about like
superman you're not like changing a
letter or anything you're like
doing your own i was gonna be superman
that's pretty good yeah superman yeah
superman
superman that's really good superman's
cool
like alone you suck but together yeah
it's like a dual anyway like that
superman
you're starting at the sequel too which
i like a lot because you get more money
for the sequel
you get way more money it's like where's
number one it never it kind of started
superman yeah and then ten years later
you do a
number one like star wars you reboot it
with superman again
you're already stuck on the secret oh
yeah you can't reboot superman like that
i feel like there should be one where
it's like if it's good you can't for
like maybe 200 years
if it's shitty it should be 10 years no
well who determines it's so subjective
ratings are wrong tomatoes you obviously
oh that's true yes you know that's it
they're good
yeah absolutely they're legit i feel
like if it's
a company that's still like alive and
thriving and using it
then they should be able to still
continue holding on to it yeah what's
the argument against that
i would like to know so like i said
things that are pop culture get
ingrained into your culture
and the idea is that they're not
necessarily owned by one entity
anymore when it's been that long since
the original part of your your
maybe your word or maybe the better way
of phrasing it is disney should not have
access to their own stuff for over 100
years
okay i like [ __ ] up their own movies
and they ruin
lions lion's king forget the disney
thing let's talk about dc
what was the movie lion king lion king
aladdin so they're saying here that
um so this is like a little excerpt from
this one website it says in fact since
copyright used to come
in renewable terms of 28 years and 85
percent of authors did not renew
85 of the works from 1992
might be entering the public domain is
it because they got lazy
i don't know the reasons maybe it costs
money and they just didn't have the
money
um bro but do they still get money say i
write something 100 years later
um if someone takes it now because it's
public domain oh i guess that's probably
domain then it just
becomes yeah nobody gets you don't get
royalties or whatever
right i do think people are lazy though
because i remember
stephen king came out one year right and
he was like hey for this book
uh anyone that's a film student can go
ahead and adapt it
because you really want to like one for
one dollar yeah cause you really wanted
to hook people up
and i haven't heard anything yeah
because you know why because i think it
was not his best [ __ ] i think he took
his table scraps and he fed the dogs
because it was like a lot of books but
it was all like for a dollar you could
buy the
copyright yeah and to adapt it but how
many more people write like
short stories dude the cat writes like a
book a day he writes so
much if you have that much horror in
your heart yeah he does
he's got to get it out too that's so
scary that's crazy unless his wife is
his inspiration
oh that makes sense it's stupid when we
were in colorado we did
visit the hotel that inspired the
shining
oh yeah we weather too yeah yeah stanley
hotel
i ate brussels sprouts there oh no the
did they film [ __ ] uh harry and lloyd
there um
really dumb and dumber dumb and dumber
yeah is that right yeah
areas at the bar that is at that hotel
our tour guide so we did a tour right
and then our tour guide told us of this
story from jim
carrey staying at that hotel that he
only made it i think three hours
in the hotel and he was he immediately
requested to get the [ __ ] out of the
stanley
he stayed at another hotel because it's
all weird to him no no so
apparently it's like a really haunted
hotel and so there's like certain
specific room
no no there's there's certain there's
different rooms that have different
activity from different ghosts or
whatever but the one room that he stayed
in is the most active and it's the one
that inspired the shining
and that one and they hooked him up
right yeah and then that one
um apparently like the so it was who was
she like a housekeeper or something
yeah someone that worked at the hotel
yeah and so apparently like if any guest
that stays in that room and they're just
messy people
like she'll make you like she'll she'll
let you know that she's there and that
she doesn't like your mess and she wants
you out and i don't know what she does
but that's just how
jim carrey was a messy boy and so
apparently jim carrey
he got freaked the [ __ ] out and he never
wanted to stay there again
and also he requested to never film
there ever again yeah how hot was she
i don't know but anyway jeff never gets
all the info it drives me
[Laughter]
you know maybe i shouldn't have done out
of ten can you just start to factor in
out of ten how high
listen maybe i shouldn't have gotten a
career of journalism
i'm so bad at it you know just make it
up like most of these people do
yeah like the other journalists they
just you're a good company
in my opinion our best journalist has to
live in venezuela because our government
wants to hunt him down for being too
good of journalists so
you're fine is that the julian assange
that's the
the snowden breakup this news channel is
missing weather
it is we should do a weather channel
we've never done one weather report
today uh east asian get naked on the
camera weather
well no here's the thing joe man our
videos come out like two weeks late
by the time they get the weather it's
like bro that was [ __ ] december
not helpful that's what makes it funny
yeah that's what our internal polling
has shown is that us doing weather would
not be helpful
it's not prepare your umbrella guys so
we do all kinds of news
except for weather that's what we need
to workshop guys how can we get the
weather
you know what we'll do like probably a
lot of views we should do one for like
the next episode that comes out like
next week
that uh there might be a pandemic oh
that's pretty good
people click on it just to tell like
this is late you know we should actually
but when we get there like how we
tricked you we got your view and clicks
we should do a sample we should do a
sample or test weather episode to see
how it does maybe we'll be pretty good
at it who would be the weatherman you
all of us maybe dallas reigns we go
around the room and and talk about
different territories
yeah we tell all the weather what's
what's the weather like in l.a right now
well it's balmy you better put on a coat
there i don't even know there's no
windows in here it's going to be about
55 in the day and 55 in l.a
you're going to cut down to about 37
tonight actually let me see colts lost
today
i dress poorly for this
anyway the reason why i'm talking about
great gatsby though
is because the internet and particularly
twitter
they are all saying oh my god
we need a muppets version of the great
gatsby that's the first thing they went
to is a muppets version yup
yup do they get the copyright or i like
it has twitter seen the great gatsby
that's exactly what people said too they
were like you really want to see kermit
the frog dead on the pool
yeah why i do know now that you said
that
i'd be down they can't make it like all
happy and like
like kids friendly you know that's kind
of sick it's to be a pg there's nothing
this is pretty sarcastic though it's
pretty funny but i want to see kermit's
brains blown out i do too i want to see
all the all the cotton now i want to see
all every single piece of cotton now
hilarious
[Laughter]
puss out too i need to see all that
cotton
cotton's not bad like it'd be better
than it would be horrifying for a child
to see if you could
they killed carmen we didn't really get
gatsby kids sorry
you know right like his [ __ ] plastic
guy better be like this
[Music]
foreign